comment tu te démerdes par des tickets
de péage pour les revendre toi oui cette
fois ci j'ai même les tickets gagnants
de la prochaine tombola n'a fait de la
police
cette note qui font tourner de nouveau
ça fait cher le le ticket non
non parce que je vous dis ça parce que
moi j'en ai des pêcheurs c'est pour ça
vous l'avez liés aux échos un autre
autre longue oui ça se voit pas
bon là c'est parce que je suis pas bien
habillé de ce qu'il fait chaud mais si
un juge contrôleur de l'autoroute
entre le rapport le rapport c'est que
vous allez donner ce ticket là où
monsieur oph la barre et vous allez
payer 13 points au lieu de payer 180
parce que c'est moins loin
c'est là-bas que le fait que je fais
tous coincés là bah oui
d'accord pour me régler tout de suite
qu'ils avaient bien avant vous allez me
ralentit qu'il est bon
mais un
ticket valable à ma bonne foi mais là
mais ce que j'ai fait ce que j'ai l'air
malhonnête est ce que j'ai l'air maloney
c'est ayem mais est ce que j'ai l'air
malhonnête est-ce que c'est malhonnête
ce que je fais je sais pas comment je
connais pas ce maintien - situation
c'est un chien doute me le dit sinon
j'ai des tickets pour le concert de guy
béart là sur l'air de repos un peu plus
loin dans une demi heure sur les
intéresse
pas y'a rien de drôle
ce qui fait ça c'est les aires de repos
il fait ce qu'il peut
50 50
et pour le prix je vous donne celui-là
aussi tiens moi aussi vos souvenirs
n'avait pas dans votre collègue celui-là
ah bon vous êtes pas du tout non pas du
tout ticket d'autoroute au fil
merci c'est moi qui veux remercier
thomas quoi je vais passer vous pensez
qu'ils vont pas voir qu'ils sachent et
pas faudra faire comme si vous venez de
pas très loin quoi
comme vous êtes un peu bronzé mettez une
crème blanche
bonjour le plaisir ont quitté sous
yasser c'est bon
[Musique]